[Music]
my co-author Erik Brynjolfsson and I are
both at MIT and we have a colleague at
MIT who said something that really helps
me understand some of the last human
work that I think is ever going to be
automated by even really sophisticated
technology our colleagues name is Deb
Roy he's at the Media Lab and he points
out that we humans are incredibly deeply
social creatures were just a social
species and you say okay so what so are
ants
so are honeybees so are chimpanzees
Deb's point is that the nature of human
social interaction involves some really
deeply rooted social drives that don't
appear to be present in any other animal
we came across a great quote when we
were writing machine platform crowd from
a sociologist or a primatologist who
said look you will never ever see two
chimpanzees carrying a log that that
notion of cooperation is absent from
even our closest non-human relatives so
that gives me a whole new way to think
about the kind of work that's very
that's most innately deeply human it's
the work that taps into our social
drives and those drives are both
positive they're solidarity and pride
and compassion for other human beings
and they're negative they can be envy
they can be shame they can be jealousy
they can be a antipathy towards some
kind of other group out there but we
have these drives they are very very
deep they're very strong and they're
kind of hard to fool with technology so
there are a lot of jobs out there that
that tap into that make use of that try
to harness those social drives and one
of my favorite examples of a job that we
don't think of as this incredibly elite
job or this incredibly prestigious job
but a job that is very unlikely I
believe to be replaced by technology
anytime soon is a just a like a girl
soccer coach and that girl soccer coach
may or may not be a strategic genius
about the game of soccer but what that
person can do if they're any good at
their job they can motivate
group of girls to come together to
overcome rivalries and jealousies and
different kinds of pettiness and play
together as a team they can teach the
value of some of those social drives
like solidarity they can help some girls
who are natural leaders but might be
going through a difficult period in
their lives get past that and assume the
roles that they're going to be good at
they can just deal in this incredibly
rich mix of social things that are going
on let's say we could build a computer
that could figure out all the different
social things that are happening among a
group of 25 12 year old girls I think
that computer is actually a long way off
but let's say we could even build that
computer would that computer with that
robot be able to motivate those girls
draw them together tease out what each
is really good at get them to overcome
fatigue and self-doubt and all these
things realize if they were having
problems in the rest of their lives and
and how to help them through that again
one thing I've learned with technology
is Never Say Never
that automatic soccer coach feels like
it's a long long long way away for me so
if I take that example and I project it
out there are a lot of people who do
some work that feels a lot like that and
those are teachers those are managers
those are folks who might be taking care
of our more vulnerable populations and I
think about the very young the sick the
elderly the infirm there are a lot of
those vulnerable people out there
because of the richness of our social
lives and our social drives I just don't
see anyone even really great innovators
coming up with technologies that can
just substitute for the people who are
currently doing those very very social
jobs
[Music]